avec 13,1 pour cent à l'issue de ce
premier tour des régionales en
ile-de-france jordan bordât et la liste
du rassemblement national termine en
deuxième position là où en 2015 son
prédécesseur vallerand de saint-just
totalisé plus de 18% des voix
un échec pour le jeune homme de 25 ans
élu député européen en 2019 est
aujourd'hui deuxième vice président de
son parti qui appelle au vote de pas
voter
restez chez vous renoncez à vous rendre
dans les bureaux de vote et à faire
votre devoir de citoyen s'est laissé
entre eux c'est les laisser entre eux et
sait faire à emmanuel macron et à son
gouvernement le plus beau des cadeaux
renoncé à faire entendre votre voix
si l'île de france n'a jamais été une
région acquise au rassemblement national
force est de constater que son programme
axé principalement sur la sécurité n'a
pas pleinement convaincu même au sein de
son électorat
le second tour qui s'annonce avec une
gauche unie pourrait le reléguer au
troisième voire en quatrième position
même si ses partisans ont une tout autre
lecture du scrutin le point de vue de
l'île de france ne sommes absolument pas
déçu je pense qu'il peut il confirme
qu'il est le premier opposant à valérie
pécresse donc de ce point de vue là nous
sommes confiants envers jordan bordel
dans les yvelines la liste du
rassemblement national mené par laurent
maurin réalise néanmoins un meilleur
score qu'au niveau régional avec plus de
14%
elle met toujours à près de 30% de la
présidente sortante en les conditions de
ce scrutin ont donné une prime aux
sortants une prime au sortant
dans beaucoup de régions en région
ile-de-france en région hôte france et
dans d'autres certainement et bien sûr
dans ces conditions là il était très
difficile de rivaliser et d'attendre
d'atteindre les
les scores qui était donné par les
sondeurs pour le second tour jordan
bardella et ses colistiers tenteront de
faire mieux que les 12 sièges obtenus en
ile de france en 2015